con darle salud ya de paso hace unos
años tenía condenas de mi casa hicieron
de estas plantaciones departamentales a
pedir asesoría
está en uno de los pasillos esperándome
llega el asesor cuando se acercó una
chica joven con el informe de la tienda
y me preguntó si yo era la persona que
necesitaba asesoría
mi primera impresión fue de rechazo la
verdad no me dio mucha confianza
en la casa
yo esperaba que un hombre grande y
fuerte me dijera cómo cómo hacer eso
pero conforme ya empezó a hablar me di
cuenta que ella sabía del tema y que yo
sabía
esta experiencia marcó mi vida porque
comprendí realmente que los prejuicios
que tenemos los vamos aprendiendo de
nuestra cultura de nuestra sociedad y
que son realmente fuertes y que van a
afectar la forma en la que pensamos en
la que razonamos y como la forma en que
interactuamos con otras personas
y contarles como los prejuicios de
género afectan el desarrollo del
conocimiento científico en una rama de
la biología que estudia el
comportamiento sexual
la revolución sexual con la cual
explicaba por qué algunos machos tienen
armamentos como gastarnos comportó muy
grande y otros medios tienen ornamentos
como una clonación boris tosa y plumas
exuberantes estamos hablando
y los científicos de esa época
inmediatamente si me ayuda
los científicos de esa época
inmediatamente acercaron la idea de que
los armamentos en los animales
evolucionan porque les permiten
organizar a las cebras el sol es cuando
los machos pelean aquellos machos que
tienen armamentos más grandes o fuertes
son los que ganan las peleas se quedan
con las hembras se reproducen con ellas
y pasa sus características de una
generación
sin embargo los científicos de esa época
no aceptaron la idea de los ornamentos
en los machos evolucionan con lo que se
ha hablado de fieles
es que todos los machos y las hembras
van a quedarse solamente con aquellos de
ellas en 4
tiene muchas razones por las cuales la
comunidad científica no aceptó la idea
de la dirección de pareja
y una de ellas es que realmente no había
antecedentes sexuales
pero también habla de frenos culturales
aunque la teoría de la evolución
avanzada
uno de ellos es que para aceptar que hay
en esa pareja en el reino animal primero
hay que reconocer que los animales
tienen que tener que picar
pero los esquemas para la sociedad
el otro freno que fue más importante es
que la sociedad victoriana creía que una
mujer no podía ser fuerte activa obtener
poder de decisión
es por eso que utilizaron al creyente
ésta era la peor de sus ideas que era
absurdo que los ornamentos de los machos
evolucionan porque las hembras los
eligen
durante casi todo el siglo 20 la teoría
de la selección sexual quedó olvidada
fue hasta los setentas gracias al
trabajo de científicos como trivés fish
y james harvey que los biólogos
evolutivos comenzaron con la posibilidad
regresión de parejas del reino animal
100 años de retraso en el conocimiento
científico que afectaron no sólo a la
biología sino también a la psicología a
la antropología a las ciencias
cognitivas a la paleontología a las
ciencias sociales y humanidades porque
durante todo este tiempo no pudieron
incluir los estudios el hecho de que la
selección sexual moldea la mente de los
humanos su cuerpo su comportamiento
cultural
hoy en día la selección sexual es un
área de la biología con mucho
reconocimiento es una de las áreas más
activas
durante las últimas cinco décadas hemos
reunido muchas evidencias de que la
dirección de pareja existe en insectos y
peces
reptiles mamíferos hoy nadie
sexual ocurre en la naturaleza y sin
embargo todavía en prejuicios de género
que frenan el desarrollo del
conocimiento científico
uno de ellos tiene que ver con la de los
roles tradicionales de los esos
generalmente la naturaleza las hembras
eligen y los machos overos pero en los
últimos años nos hemos dado cuenta de
que estos errores no son estrictos de
que las hembras también pueden competir
los machos y también pueden ser
promiscuos y que los machos también
pueden tener en hechos de pareja genera
beneficios reproductivos
y entonces yo los invito a pensar porque
es que estos sexos tienen las diferentes
estrategias de elegir y competir
bueno el fundamento es la impresión
procesos para que resulta en un
potencial reproductivo diferente para
ambos sexos
este es el caso de los pies
piense en el hombre que más dijo
toda la historia de la humanidad
cuando sostuvo
los análisis genéticos muestran que el
punto cinco por ciento de toda la
regulación mundial son sus descendientes
ahora piensen en las mujeres que más
hijos ha tenido en toda la historia de
la humanidad
cuando digo todo
una mujer rusa que cada vez que para
ella tenía mellizos trillizos
cuatrillizos
estamos viendo entonces la diferencia en
el potencial reproductivo de macho
ciertas y en una consecuencia directa de
las estrategias diferentes y entonces
los machos se benefician cuando
aumenta su éxito reproductivo
produciendo facilidad en los machos y
las hembras
pero como les comento estos roles
tradicionales de género no son estilos y
entonces un ejemplo de esto es los
pájaros los pájaros se han usado siempre
como un ideal de la realidad porque
crían a sus ponerlos en monogamia
para sorpresa de todos cuando se
desarrollaron los primeros marcadores
enérgicos que nos ayudaban a la
paternidad de la naturaleza la mayoría
de las especies
[Música]
y ello quiere decir que no encontrarán
huevos de su pareja pero también los
otros machos
y entonces hemos exportado muchos
edificios que las células se obtienen al
aparearse múltiples veces
un beneficio es que las siembras en
algunas especies obtienen además de los
espermatozoides ricos nutrientes que
están en el eyaculado y que reciben allá
para tener mayor energía para producir
mayor no lo de crías
pero también hablaría con una diferente
significa que aumenta la probabilidad de
producir variación genética en las
relaciones
es como no poner todos los huevos en una
sola canasta sino repartir los en
canastas diferentes y así producir
iglesias para el aliento
las cebras no suelo son promiscuas las
hembras también compiten por los machos
y lo hacen cuando hay pocos de ellos
entonces una fiesta una boda en donde a
estas mujeres en estas situaciones la
competencia se disparan
esta naturaleza también se llama
nacional de los sexos
ahora los sesgos de género no sólo
afectan la manera en la que terceriza
las hembras también afectan cómo
conseguimos el comportamiento sexual de
los machos
yo me dedico estudiar son la imagen son
peces tropicales y han sido introducidos
en casi todo el mundo son ingleses muy
conocidos por los acuaristas uno de los
más populares
y tienen un fuerte y machismo sexual qué
quiere decir que los machos y las
hembras son muy diferentes los machos
tienen estos patrones de coloración con
colores muy llamativos naranja negro
colores deficientes
también tienen altos rendimientos de las
cenas
y entonces tienen reproducción eterna
del cuerpo el macho tiene una letra
modificada con las maduras quieren el
esperma acciones libros van a hacer de
dos formas pueden dejar si la aceptan
entonces se posicionan a la ayuda de la
hembra
pero los machos también pueden hacer
populares posadas
esto quiere decir que se acerca
los dos pasan 50 de su tiempo acosando a
las cebras de hecho una es la de recibir
un efecto de cópula dorsal por minuto
y es por eso que algunas poblaciones las
hembras prefieren ir a las zonas del río
más profundas donde hay depredadores
los buques son un ejemplo de los roles
de género estereotipados o tradicionales
pero es erróneo etiquetar a los sexos de
esta forma
durante mi nombre ha demostrado que los
machos no son estas máquinas sexuales
desenfrenadas que digamos por ejemplo en
un estudio que hice entre vida de los
que los machos pueden reconocer grupos
de peces en el río que contienen hembras
respectivas así es que no pierdan su
tiempo con grupos de peces
tampoco contiene su energía compitiendo
con otros machos para tener acceso a
hembras preñadas que no son de seriedad
de hecho los machos han evolucionado la
capacidad de distinguir al hacer la
tarea 2
junto con estudiantes también nos hemos
argumenta que los machos cuando tiene
poca reserva espermática los objetivos
generales los útiles prefiere las
grandes pero si nosotros en el
laboratorio artificialmente les
estaremos el esperma no están deseando
los estos machos ya los otros directivos
ni tampoco ponen tanto esfuerzo para tal
de conquistar a las hembras
estas máquinas sexuales tienen aparece
sino que tienen preferencias que les
ayudan a tener
los valores de género que implícitamente
han competido de nuestra cultura de
nuestra sociedad van a influenciar la
forma en la que pensamos y la forma en
la que nos relacionamos con sus
compañeros de trabajo familia amigos y
en mi caso con una trabajadora en una
tienda
cuando ustedes han tenido prejuicios de
género
otra vez es alumno inicio ha elegido a
ser uno de ustedes
yo nunca es muy difícil darnos con por
completo estos tipos de estrés los
culturales
pero estoy segura de que los elementos
como éste en donde hablamos y discutimos
del tema nos va a ayudar a identificar
la próxima vez en la que un sesgo de
género está influenciando a nuestro
comportamiento y vale la pena seguir
hablando del asunto
muchas gracias organizadores
[Aplausos]